Now, everybody, welcome to another episode of Cholistic Health Hours, this is Dr. Kevin
Thudders.
We're going to do our best to answer some of your health questions, holistically, from
a natural perspective.
I'll agree.
Let's say that.
Okay.
So remember, you go to holistichealthour.com.
You can see all our past episodes, very well indexed on different questions that people
have asked.
So if you've got a question, you can't get it on, please do that.
And you can chat in your questions today on that holistic health hour.com site.
You can ask questions, and that's where we're getting these questions from people who have
asked questions the last week.
So let's jump to the questions.
Number one, I have come across some suggestions and different B vitamins and things to add to
someone with Parkinson's disease, is this something you would recommend and have you
follow that Parkinson's can be reversed?
Well, that's a tough question.
Parkinson's can be reversed, Parkinson's is typically a mute attack, many times auto mute
attack, part of the brain called the substantiate diagram, which is the deep in the midbrain, that's
the only part of the brain that makes dopamine, and dopamine is essential as a amino acid,
as after a transmitter for smoothed out movements, as far as its connection with the frontal
motor cortex and the cerebellum, and the deficiency in dopamine leads to a disease called Parkinson's
disease.
Can taking supplements help?
Yeah, clean up your diet can help.
Decreasing the brain inflammation is probably your best help.
Supported through, typically for the medical intervention, is medication that's going to replace
dopamine, and dopamine, but probably is that tends to only last for a period of a couple
years, and then it just doesn't work as well anymore.
So it's a progressive disorder, and there is a daily magic medicine that is going to cure
Parkinson's.
However, what has been found is that inflammation in the brain is at least a contributor
to it, that in fact, you can test for neural antibodies and get a pretty good idea that you
have a possibility of early Parkinson's, or you could catch it at an early stage and you
could start doing some things about it.
So the test that you would test for, that would be a Syrex Array 7x, which would test for
neural antibodies.
It's not a perfect test, but it's a good indicator of all sorts of different inflammatory markers
that have caused antibodies to neural tissue that you can now start to make interventions.
Many people only do that test after they have neural symptoms, meaning some upper motor
neuron symptoms, some early Parkinson's, some early dementia, though it would be better
to do it before you have those symptoms, so you can start being more proactive.
However, what do you do with that?
If that's positive, what do you do if you already have a Parkinson's diagnosis?
Well, you have to decrease brain inflammation, that's your number one purpose, you got to find
sources that are causing an increase in inflammation in the brain.
So, the increase in brain inflammation, you think of different nutritional supplements like
flavonoids, curcumin, boswellia, stingy dental, that kind of thing, corsetin, those
are the fluids that can help increase brain inflammation, but if you have a source that's
causing an increase in inflammation, do you know where the bowel, if you don't decrease
that source?
So, dealing with food sensitivities, gluten is the most cutting that's going to cause brain
inflammation, certainly dairy, other food sensitivities could cause that.
Looking at tests to measure blood-brained barrier, permeability issues, and working on that,
and improving that can be beneficial, increasing oxygenation to the brain, one of the best things
that I've seen for people with Parkinson's is to do hyperbaric chamber.
The negative of that is you have to do it on a regular basis, meaning daily, so it's almost
better to have a hyperbaric chamber in your house.
Certainly, different supplements can be beneficial, but I'd really concentrate on the anti-inflammatory
things with Parkinson's, and I'd really concentrate on biting sources of inflammation.
Okay, next question, when you see, let's get to the chat question here.
How does the SBI pro-dietary supplement work to assist in a follicular, non-hodgic lymphoma,
I'd just be going to use it there?
So, the SBI pro-supplement is aoglobulin, so there's a lot of different amytoclobulin
supplements out there that can be really helpful for the gut, so mutoglobulins take it as
a supplement to help decrease the inflammation in the gut, so they kind of act like a spun,
the grab on, the stuff in the gut to get it out of the gut, so it decreases inflammation
in the gut, and remember, when you have inflammation systemically, whether it's inflammation
in the brain, or it's inflammation of the tissues, when we decrease inflammation of the
gut, we're going to decrease systemic inflammation.
So the purpose of doing, so how's lymphoma, why would you take, you know, to work on gut inflammation
if I have lymphoma, well, working on gut inflammation can help systemic inflammation, so it can help
any disorder, speaking of Parkinson's, working on it, I mentioned one of the major components
of Parkinson's is trying to find sources of inflammation in the brain, and I mentioned dietary
things like getting rid of gluten and dairy and things like that, and you're diet, and
people might go, what is he talking about, dealing with gluten, I have Parkinson's, how's
that relate?
Well, you have, in inflammatory processes that go out of the gut are going to cause inflammation
systemically, so any time you can decrease inflammation that gut, you're going to decrease inflammation
systemically, so that would be the mechanism of action there.
Next question, when using alternative therapies for cancer that has arrived supplements, diet,
et cetera, and tracking my tumor markers, how can one interpret? I had a 10-point rise in the
first two months of an alternative therapy, and most recently only a five-point rise within a month,
is that a positive improvement, or if the amount of increases less than previous, or is there any
increase a negative sign? Okay, so how do you interpret a tumor marker test that you're doing
any type of care? For those who don't know who don't have cancer, tumor markers are different
proteins that different cancers may or may not give off. Let's use CA-199 as an example, so CA-199
is a tumor marker. No, there are dozens and dozens of different tumor, so let's use your PSA,
as an example, so PSA, more people are more aware of PSA prostate specific antigen, is a tumor marker
for prostate cancer. Now, that's only going to be for prostate cancer, so somebody is not going to
have an elevated PSA with colon cancer, but some of the other tumor markers are not as specific,
so like CA-199 that I mentioned, that could be elevated with pacreatic cancer, that could be elevated
with breast cancer, that could be elevated with even with colon cancer, though not as common,
but if a person has prostate cancer, 99% of the time their PSA is going to be elevated, but if a person
has pacreatic cancer, there's a much smaller percentage of the time their CA-199 will be elevated,
maybe it's 80% of the people with prostate cancer, I don't have those statistics, but with
breast cancer, there are several tumor markers, there's CA-153, there's CA-199, there's CEA,
there's CA-25, 27-25, and those should be done on every woman with breast cancer,
because one woman might have an elevated CA-153,
then another woman might have normal CA-153 and an elevated CA-199, so it isn't guaranteed that
your cancer, if you have cancer that your tumor markers are going to be elevated, but the benefit
of doing tumor markers is that it gives you a non-invasive way to measure progress if your tumor markers,
if you do show one or more tumor marker that is elevated, it gives you a more non-invasive way
to measure progress upcare, meaning that, okay, I have to go get a blood draw to measure
my tumor markers versus I'm going to get a CT scanner MRI or PET scan, those are fairly invasive
MRI, well, you start to get galledium as a dye, that can be invasive CT scan as radiation,
as well as PET scan as radiation, and cost-wise, you know, cost you less than $100 to do a
tumor marker panel, cost you $20 to a PSA test, so it can be less invasive, you can do it on a more
regular basis, so you could do tumor markers on a monthly basis, so this question is being asked,
if I have an elevated tumor marker, let's say this person has breast cancer, let's say their CA-153
is elevated, and as they're starting a course of care, whether they're doing standards of care,
whether they're doing alternative care, the numbers are going up, and as through that course of care,
let's say it's the first two months, it's going up 10 points, well, when was your first baseline?
Well, you always have to get a baseline, and it's a shame that more oncologists don't run tumor markers
right away with a person as a diagnosis of cancer, because then that will give that person a
baseline, so wherever we draw that baseline of that first blood test, and then your measuring
subsequent blood tests to see, you know, which direction things are going, if things are, you know,
slowing down and starting to level out and starting to go down, that's what we want, but many times,
when you start a course of care, your baseline is, let's say, whatever it is, 53 out of CA-153,
let's say it went up to 63, then 73, and then it's down to 68, which would be a
similar interpretation of this person's question, is that a good side or bad side? Well,
to me, it's not an update, so, you know, you can have a five-point swing in a tumor worker test,
and it doesn't give us, it doesn't tell us, what you're really looking for a tumor worker test is
it really, except for PSA maybe, but your CA-199-153, and 27-25, is it like doubly? That's where you get
concern, what a number goes way up, that's where you start to get concerned, when it's just
crawled up and then crawled back down, we don't really know that we can assess care
components at that time. The second part of this question is, any increase in negative side?
Well, yeah, you know what, your numbers to go the wrong way, but it can take time
for things to change in your body to heal in your body to attack this. I will say one of the reasons
why oncologists don't like to use the tumor marker tests is they will say that they're not very
accurate, and I will give them the okay and the answer because they aren't very accurate if the
person is doing chemotherapy as well. So, what chemotherapy does, is chemotherapy,
hopefully, if it's working, it's going to destroy a cancer cell through a process of
lysis, so it's going to cause that cancer cell to die quickly, and it can cause a spike in tumor
markers. So, when tumor markers were first discovered years ago, it was this huge aha moment for
practice of oncologists, we're going to use tumor markers to monitor this person's care,
promise what is an oncologist recommending, or the recommended chemotherapy. And what was found
was that when a person is doing chemotherapy and you're getting rapid death of cancer cells,
you can get a spike in the tumor markers because the cancer cells are died and then you're
spilling out this enzyme, the tumor marker, and it will show in the blood that's elevated and people
freak out. Oh my gosh, I'm going through chemotherapy, I'm feeling sick, you're telling me that it's
getting better, you're ready, there's tumor records tested, it's doubled, tripled. This is not good,
but it's a false positive. So, when a cancer dies quickly, it can spill out more tumor markers,
and it can give a false positive and an elevated test. Therefore, a lot of oncologists have
scrapped tumor markers. That's why they don't run them because they're expecting everybody to follow
their course of care, which is chemotherapy, and they got hired and explained to people that
that could actually be a good sign when you get a spike of a tumor marker. It's hard to explain
that to a person when you're saying this is a good way to monitor or care. But when you have a crawl
upwards and a crawl downwards, you have to have more time to assess those numbers.
Be careful to put all your state in anything, whether it be a CT scan, an MRI, or a PET scan,
or blood tests. You want to look at trends. So, trends are the most important thing that you're looking at.
You can have these false changes, your blood changes, wherever it's just taking a sample of your
blood that's measuring, what's in that sample? And other things can cause variation of all your
blood tests. So, you want to look at things over time, and you want to look at things in connection
to other things. So, any objective test that you're doing, you want to measure that with other
objectives tests and with subjective findings. So, you don't take one test, and you make a critical
decision completely based upon that test. You take that test that gives you clues. So,
tumble markers are the same thing. My two markers are going up, electives are clues, because the
cancer beginning worse, could we just be putting the breaks on the cancer at this point in time?
What are your other things that you're looking for? How does the patient feel? What are their
CDC and their complete metabolic panel telling us? You know, what our, you know, has the patient's
symptom changed over this period of time? How has it changed? So, you look at as many different
markers as you can to make a clinical judgment, and that's how you go through the process of
differential diagnosis. So, hopefully that will help. Next question. I have a true rife, and it was
wondering if I cover it with my sheet, or if I am under a blanket, does it lessen the effectiveness?
No. So, it'll still go through your clothing. You don't have to have a skin-to-skin contact with
a rife machine with a bulb. So, the farther it gets away from you, you decrease the effect of this.
So, if you have the bulb, you know, 12 inches away from you, it's not going to be as strong
as far as the amp output and penetration of your body as if it's right next to you. You have it
4 feet away from you. It's going to be even less penetration. So, the closer it is to you, the better.
If you have, you know, sheet over it, or your pajamas between it, that's not going to be an issue.
Okay. This person asks two questions very similar. I have colon cancer with the
gastrosis to my lungs. Recently, I have had lyridio spasm twice, which is very scary.
Is there anything I can do at home to help with this? Thank you for advice.
So, lyridio spasm can be from multiple different causes to that. But when a person says they have
metastasis to the lungs, then it's always a concern that is there. Is there the cancer that's in
the lungs? Where is it? Is it putting pressure on a nerve that's causing the lyridio spasm?
Is it a space-occupied lesion that's pressing on the airflow? I don't know, for sure. So, we'd really
need more data to help with this. Dealing with metastasis to the lungs, you know, you think about one of
the things you could do to help with the metastasis to the lungs, you think of hiding your peroxide,
nebulized. Make sure you follow the Dr. Gercola Nebulized Recipe for hydropoxia. You don't
nebulize straight hydropoxia, you have to water it out. You think corniceps is a good supplement
as far as lung inflammation and lung healing the lungs. Anything that's going to decrease
inflammation will also be a benefit to this person. Corniceps is a medicine mushroom that is
also an adaptogen, but it's really good for the lungs. Those are the things I would think of.
And you'd want to get more data, though, is it the space-occupied this quality of the lesion
and the lung? The issue is it the location of that lesion and the lung that's putting pressure on a
nerve? Is it pressure on the airflow, bronchial, passages? You don't want to get a little bit more
data to find out what the cause of that is. Question from the chat. Would you advise to use the
right-fishing program parasites, all frequency, in combination with using i-verbectin
and alternating bandizol on a monthly basis, if so often? No, I would not. So a purpose of cancer
person, cancer patient, using i-verbectin and bandizol isn't to kill parasites. So I thought those
were anti-paracidic medications. They are, but that's not the mechanism of action with using those
off-label drugs for somebody who has a diagnosis of cancer. It works differently to help stimulate
apoptosis. That's how they work, not for the sake of parasite kill. So can a person with cancer also
have parasites that would make them want to use the right parasite off frequency? The answer is yes,
you can. That's a possibility. So there's not anything wrong with doing the parasite program on the
right, but you wouldn't do it in conjunction with bandizol because thinking that that's why I'm
taking bandizols because I have a parasite. That's the problem and the cause of my cancer. It's
different mechanism. So hopefully that answers that question. The lower ed inflammation help
kidney function. If I consume too much salt, my legs in equals swell up for several days. I have rare
and have rare occurrences in gout. Blood tests are normal except for by GFR, your merular filtration rate
which is 65. Okay so will lower ed inflammation help kidney function?
Yes, will lower ed inflammation help pretty much any every organ and tissue. As far as a person
reacting to salt, if they have too much salt, their legs and ankles swell, that can be an issue with
kidney issues. So obviously if your GFR is elevated, we have kidney issues, possible kidney damage
at some point in time. And excretion of salt is an issue and that's causing you to retain
your water, causing the legs swelling. So yeah, absolutely. So lastly, the thing about salt,
person can have a salt sensitivity that's very common with different autoimmune diseases. There's
different than different labs. I think I can go into that. I think I shared some of the research
in the autoimmune course about salt sensitivity. Why some people will have salt sensitivity and
salt increases their blood pressure and some people can eat salt like it's the, you know,
high on the food triangle. They don't have any issues whatsoever. It has to do with salt sensitivity.
Some people is a trigger. So we talk about autoimmune diseases and looking for triggers,
salt can be a trigger. So the interesting thing with people that have salt as a trigger for autoimmune
issues, if they take a fairly higher dose of potassium with a salty meal, then it doesn't cause a
problem. It basically negates that trigger that might be something to look into too. But definitely
if you're holding water, you want to make sure that you're helping increase kidney function
and help with detoxification pathways. Our course on detoxification, the seventh phase in detoxification
goes into that a little bit too. As far as gout goes, so gouty arthritis is an inflammatory arthritis.
So if you have issues with gout, you know you have issues with inflammation.
And you think, oh, well, I got swelling. So I have inflammation. Well, that's inflammation because
of water retention. But definitely if you have, if you have episodes of gout, you have
inflammatory processes that are going on. So looking for triggers for that inflammation
are going to be really important and try to decrease the inflammation. It's going to be really important.
I've had patients that have had, you know, rheumatoid arthritis diagnosis or gouty arthritis
or psoriatic arthritis, inflammatory arthritis diagnosis and just literally change their diet
and their pain goes away. It can take several months, but we've seen their pain just literally
melt away. And it's because you're eating foods that are inflammatory to your body, go back to the
what's inflammation and the gout is going to be systemic inflammation. So you're eating foods that
are inflammatory that got you're going to cause systemic inflammation. And then you can get a
diagnosis of all sorts of different names. And it gets down to cleaning up that person's diet,
cleaning up their gout. That's going to bring health to so many areas. So that's what I would
highly recommend. Start there. Next question, how can I get an assessment of supplements I need for
detoxification? I have DNA enzymatic health issues and have been currently using some of your products
PUD1 assist, pro SOD canelaes, CVS, EHMT assist. So for those that don't understand, those are
supplements that are specific for different gene pathways. So if people have genetic defects in
their PUD1 pathways, which is a liver phase one, phase two pathway assist. That's how you get
toxins, chemicals, pesticides, things like that. If you person has done a genetic workup and they
have a lot of defects in their PUD1 pathway, that might be a product that we would that product was
specifically formulated to help with the PUD1 pathway. So if they have defects, a lot of defects
in the PUD1 pathway, we might recommend or practitioner might recommend that product called PUD1 assist.
Same thing, if you have defects in your superoxide disputes, canelaes pathways, they may recommend
SOD canelaes or a practitioner may just recommend SOD canelaes if they know they're exposed to a lot of
oxidants because SOD canelaes are into oxidants. And the same with the CVS, EHMT, their CVS
is a specific gene in the PUD1 pathway or your EHMT as another gene family. If you have
defects on those genes, then those products might be recommended. Continuing with the question to
help get rid of toxins, but looking beyond this because I did a feel well, GI, neural, circulation,
etc. I would like a personalized recommendation protocol to address my personal needs.
Yes, so if you want a personalized recommendation from us, you will want to start with what's called
case review. So if you go to our website, cuddersclinic.com, you'll see a tab that says start here or
begin here, you can click on that and cuddersclinic.com is mainly all about cancer because that's our primary
patient members that we see these days, but have for years. But we also have a sister site called
My Hope for Lyme. Similar but it talks about Lyme disease, it talks about autoimmune disease, it talks
about general functional medicine. It doesn't make any difference which site you go to.
You can self-schedule on either one of those sites at a practitioner that My Hope for Lyme
sites pushes you back to the cuddersclinic site to schedule. No, I think that's the page that you
go to the schedule. Certainly you could just call the clinic and talk to Merid or whoever answers
the phone and ask them about options, but you'd start with a case review. If you want help from us,
I mean. So if you want My Hope, start with a case review, that's a 30-minute consultation with me,
we'll do a phone consultation. And we'll go over your symptoms that may make recommendations for
different labs. We want to look at the labs that you've had done so far. And you talk about, okay,
I'm supporting these genetic pathways, but I still don't feel well. Well, you just you miss it
something. So is it something as simple as a food issue? Is it something as simple as dealing with
neuroinflammation? Also on our website, there's 1000 plus different blog posts with different
videos that go over a lot of the site. So if you're having specific neurological symptoms,
you can search for those on our blog, on our website search, or you may find more information
that will help you, but you'd start. We want to work with us. You'd want to start with a case review.
If you want to work with somebody else, I would hope that they would recommend labs that would get
to the bottom of it because you always want to get to the bottom of what is a cause of your issue.
At most times it's not genetic. It's something social. It's going to
question for the blog. Is it okay to take diet to patients first food grade for extra cleansing
if you have breast cancer? General answer to that is yes, it is. If you haven't started it now,
the only recommendation of that is to start at a lower dose, start maybe a teaspoon a day
for a period of time when you can work up to maybe a tablespoon a day or something.
But no, there's no really negative tips to that. Diatimation search is really a binder.
More than anything else, it can help sweep the gut similar to SBI Pro,
but MitoGlobe let's help decrease the inflammation probably a little better
diatimation search, but diatimation search acts more as a binder in the gut, which is good.
It's fine. It can be an anti-parasite in the gut as well.
So yeah, it can be a good thing to do. There's no real downsides to that.
Some people get absensitivities to it. It doesn't do well with them,
and I don't think it's like an antibody sensitivity, but I think it just is irritant.
So I would start slow with it. Next question. We have observed a 25-year-old granddaughter that
seems to have some struggles. Has issues with eating, repeating her words, anxiety,
had a meltdown, maybe have her history of vaping.
Supposed to be doing Candida clans as an itchy area on the back of her neck,
spreadied to scalp, have any suggestions for low income help for chiro-functional medicine.
Okay, so we'll fully understand that question, but
issues with eating, issues with repeating her words, anxiety, had a meltdown, I suppose that means
an emotional meltdown. History of vaping, so vaping, what does that pertain to anything with the
history? Well, it tends to tons of toxins. So there's a lot of heavy metals, a lot of poisons
in that vein products that people are using, so that can lead to toxins. But going back
to the symptoms, I don't have a complete, anything close to complete. History of this person,
but issues with eating, repeating her words, that was a key phrase to be, anxiety,
an emotional meltdown, then speak to neural inflammation. So that's the thing I would look at.
History of vaping, maybe other sources of toxins, you'd think of possible toxicity at her brain.
Supposed to do a Candida clans, because she has an itchy area on the back of her neck,
spreading to scalp, can need to be one of the first things I think of,
unless she had other Candida symptoms. Certainly, you could have lots of different comorbidities.
When we get ill, it's usually not, oh, here's the problem. We'll just take this out or fix this,
and now all my problems go away. When we get ill, it tends to be a domino effect and
multiple things go bad. So a person can have parasites and heavy metals and Candida issues
and toxicity to their brain, and they can have all these things that are going on at the same time.
Usually, that's what happens, that brings us. Our bodies are pretty resilient,
but it's when we get this combination of all these things breaking down their barriers
and that overwhelm our immune system, that can lead to cancer, that can overwhelm our body,
it can lead to autoimmune diseases, where immune system starts making antibodies against self tissue.
If you have to start to kind of uncover the layers with any type of disorder, you're just kind of,
you're kind of breaking down the layers and cleaning things up. So,
I'm not a functional medicine doctor who thinks everything begins in the gut and everything is
solved by this, because the best way to know what's going on is to run some labs and run some tests,
but like this question mentioned, a lot of people are in a situation, they don't have money for
labs. I don't have money to do this stuff. I don't have money to make a case review with you and
get started on a call. Well, that's where we have our courses. Our courses are $50, so doing the
autoimmune course for $50, we're constantly adding more material and more information where you can
start going through some videos and learning how to take care of yourself is the best way to go.
Problem is a lot of people that are in this situation don't have the motivation to want to take care
of themselves. Well, then I don't know what to do in that situation. Hopefully that this person
25 years old is getting to an end, getting to a bottom where they want to start
taking self responsibility. It's very difficult when you have a person that doesn't want to take
responsibility for themselves. Hard enough with a kid who you're trying to force into a dietary
program that they're not willing to do. It's certainly impossible when a person is an adult,
so they have to be willing to do something so you could lead them to some information. So if you
enjoyed one of our courses, you joined our autoimmune course and you share information with them
from a grandparent to a grand child, I don't know how open they're willing. They're going to be
receiving that information, but I'd start with just uncovering things and the way to uncover
things is to, first of all, try to decrease the toxic load this person is dealing with.
Sometimes when you just start decreasing the toxic load, the body has an unbelievable
way to heal. Are there inflammatory foods that this person's eating that they need to get rid of?
Is there support with detoxification pathways? Stop vaping, stop their poor diet. It's amazing
what you could do. All you do to a person is clean up their diet, getting them eating better,
doing a little bit of exercise and thinking better about themselves and taking responsibility and
decreasing their medications that they're taking. How the body can respond in healing can take place
without buying a whole bunch of supplements or having to do anything else. So,
start with what you can do, I guess, is the way to do it. Next question, how do you deal with
a possible pandas case? My nephew is having issues. So pandas, for those who don't know what
pans and pandas is, pans and pandas is basically inflammation in the brain,
pandas is caused from strep, but their findings, so when it was first discovered as a strep
infection, can cause damage to neural tissue caused microglial primate and severe emotional breakdown
of that person. It was typically in children and it was from strep, so it was basically an untreated
strep that went to the brain, caused neural inflammation, neural damage, many times neural antibody
production and severe emotional changes. So a pandas case would be, typical pandas case would be a
normal, healthy, happy, seven-year-old child that maybe came down with an infection, and then
literally two days later was this completely different person. That's typically what a parent would
explain. This is not by child, somebody kidnapped him overnight and replaced him with a different child,
they're defiant, they're angry, they're banging their head against the one. What has happened? Do
they have autism? What is going on? That's what pandas is. It can be, now they're finding that it can
be not just strep related, that's what pans is, so it can be not in just a child, it can be in an
adults too, so there can be multiple different causes from mycotoxins to mycoplasma, different bacterial
infections, different viral infections, post-concussive disorders, and so more and more data is coming out on
this. Treatment can be of strep is still, present can be antibiotic therapy to decrease inflammation,
so everything that I have on a video that I created a few years ago that was more specific to
microglial priming and neural antibody production, and if you go to the website, I mentioned this
multiple plastic health hours, you can go to our website, search neural inflammation, neural
inflammation, you'll see a video that I created on neural inflammation and microglial priming,
that talks about decreasing brain inflammation, so those are the things that you would look at, but
you do want to do some discovery and some labs to see exactly what's going on, you have to deal with
diet, it's diet, you've got gluten and dairy, which are gliato-morphine receptors in the gut,
in the brain, and case you'll morphine receptors, so the gut in the brain is going to cause direct
inflammation of the brain, you have to look at, from an autoimmune perspective, you have to look at
other triggers that be causing changes in mood and changes in behavior, dealing with, if it is,
bicotoxin's dealing with that, if it's heavy metals dealing with that, those would be detoxification,
if it's like a bicoplasma dealing with that, that'd be using like the knife or other
anti-infectious agents, so they're complex cases and that you could see changes in
turnarounds in these people and people get their child back, so, but not things to say,
neural inflammation is real, that speaks to that last question too, when there's just, when there's
changes in behavior, you talk about repeating words, anxiety, emotional meltdowns, those are all
called upper motor neuron issues, meaning those are brain issues, so you have to deal with
sources and causes brain inflammation, so look at that video, your own inflammation, go to our website,
search for that, go to our YouTube search for neuroinflammation under our YouTube channel or our
video channel, and you'll see, it's about a 30-minute video, microglale-private, I think that will
be well worth your time to go through that, I don't know, watch that, make it appointment with me,
we can talk about some tests that we'd love to run as well. Okay, what is the best natural way,
hold on, let's see if this other questions came in there, yes, let me get to that question too.
Do you advocate for more of a whole food plant-based eating, especially for cancer survivors like
me, I followed Chris Warx program, and that's the approach he takes, so curious what your thoughts are.
So always a whole food diet is best, so whole food is eating the whole thing,
and eating foods that we were in the best way that God created us to eat those foods, so that's a
whole food diet, plant-based eating is that the best thing to do for cancer, or someone to prevent
future cancer coming up, no, not out, so everybody's different, so it can a plant-based diet be the
right thing to do for a person if they have cancer, the answers, yes, it can be, can a plant-based diet
be the wrong diet for a person with cancer, yes, it can be, everybody's different, and sources of
cancer's growth can change over time, so a person's on a plant-based diet, their cancer
goes into remission, they're doing really well, and then the cancer comes back, so they go, they stay,
they've been on this plant-based diet, what's the deal, the cancer's found in another fuel source,
so you need to change your diet, if you can't figure that out through testing, and we do
conisiology testing to figure that out, but if you don't have that available to you,
you have to just change your diet, so cancer is constantly trying to find a fuel source
in order to grow, so if it's not, if a plant-based diet can be through a plant-based diet,
you're still getting different proteins, you're still getting
amino acids through that, and you're still getting glucose, so lots of times plant-based diet
with cancer involves juicity, which could be high in level, increasing levels of glucose,
and if glucose is your main source of that fuel for that cancer, that could be very much the wrong
diet to be on, so everybody's different is my answer,
so I don't say that every cancer patient should do this or that, now there are some things that
you could make generalities about with cancer, but not everything, so no, I don't advocate for
a plant-based eating for everybody, and I don't, another diet that's called is a ketogenic diet
for cancer patients, should all, there's books written about every cancer patient should be
out of ketogenic diet, and my answer to that is, no, that's not right, everybody is different,
would a ketogenic diet be good for me? Maybe, but maybe it's going to be the very wrong thing for you,
ketogenic diet is going to be obviously much higher in animal proteins, and if your cancer is fed
off of glutamine, then it's probably not the right diet for you at this time, so everybody is
different, another cancer diet that has been common is a raw food diet, is that good for everybody?
No, it's not, so typically a raw food diet is going to include obviously raw whole foods like
this person is asking this question, and juicity, which is going to be higher in glucose,
also you've got to think of a raw food diet, it's going to be more appropriate, the younger
of course it is, because they're going to be producing enough digestive enzymes to deal with raw
food, that cooked food, which takes a lot more pancreatic enzymes to break down, that if you
are eating your food that's more cooked, an example would be if a person has really bad gut issues,
you put them on more of a gap type diet, a gap is who that's really broken down, maybe they're
only eating super, they're only eating bone broth, now we would use bone broth with cancer patients,
so I'm using this as an example, that's all they can tolerate at this time, even a young person,
so everybody's different, I don't take a one way approach to cancer, and I don't even take a one
way approach to that specific person, because that diet for that person can change, so we might have
them on a whole food plant based diet for a period of time, and we switch them to be more of a carnivore
for a period of time, so you have to be willing to change things up, because cancer is always changing
and always trying to find a fuel source, so if that worked for you at that time, that's great,
but just be aware that it might not always work for you, and what worked for you, be careful not to say
to tell everybody that you just need to do this, because this worked for me, because it doesn't work
for everybody, nothing is going to work for everybody, all right, we have time for one more question,
should I have my amalgam fillings removed and replaced with composite fillings, is composite,
okay, or just as bad, composite is acceptable, and it is not just as bad, so your amalgam fillings,
your silver fillings are bad, they're very bad, they leech into your body, into your mouth,
and you will swallow that mercury, now if you had perfectly healthy gut in a perfect world,
you'd probably deposit that in your toilet, you don't have absorption sites for mercury,
however, the fact is that everybody has some level of leech you got,
and you will absorb that, and it's going to cause problems,
so if a person has a diagnosis of cancer, should they have their amalgam fillings out,
my answer to that is give their healthy enough, so and it also depends on the level on the industry
that's going to be involved in removing it, I just have three small fillings, I went to a biological
dentist who's going to do it the right way, use a rubber dam, have a mercury vacuum, use a nasal
cannula, have something over widows, so I'm not breathing in the gasification of that filling,
what he's drilling it out, he's doing everything right, and he said it's going to be fairly easy,
removal and replacement, then the answer be yes, but you also have to ask, am I healthy enough
right now, if more I'm going to chemo, I've really been sick that I'd say no wait, if no I'm feeling
great, then I'd say yes go for it, however, if the answer to those questions were, oh I got mercury
in all my teeth and it's just horrible, it's going to be this major, major dental
intervention to deal with this, I don't know, sometimes it's better to leave sleepy like it's
like a giant's lie, it's some it's difficult, I've had patients with cancer that
literally their teeth are just filled with mercury, they literally should probably have all
their teeth removed and just go with dentures, that would be the safest and healthiest way to deal with
things, the problem was I remember that patient, they were so ill when they came to see me,
that they would have been able to tolerate any intervention at that time, so you have to weigh
those factors out, it's never ever good to have mercury in your mouth, you always want to get your
mercury fillings removed, but you got to weigh out the level of intervention that's going to be
necessary in that process and the current level of health, and I made caveat 10 that you're going
to a biological dentist who's going to do it the right way, the worst thing you can do is go to your
dentist, he said he can just remove it, he told me it's no bank deal, he's just going to remove it,
it is a big deal, you have to do it right, you have to go to a biological dentist that's going to use
a rubber nail that's going to use a mercury vacuum, it's going to use a nasal cannula, it's going to block
your nasal passages that you're not going to breathe it in, and they're going to do things correctly,
and they take it seriously, so otherwise you don't do anything with any other dentist.
Okay, I think that's all we have time for today, remember to go to holistichealthour.com,
holistichealthour.com where you can ask your questions via the little box there, and then we have
better chance to get your questions answered. There's a few that we didn't get to, we'll get to next
week, and you can go to cuttersclinic.com and search our blog posts, we have lots and lots of them,
and you may find answers to your questions there. You can always make an appointment with me on the
self-schedule or call the clinic as well. God bless, and we'll see you guys next week.